de grosse surprise avec la défaite des
de bergues et la défaite de becker nous
le verrons à l'issue de ce 19e avec un
résumé complet de la journée avec
caroline since et jean philippe guillin
ça va mal à nouveau un gabon notamment à
port gentil la capitale économique du
pays
les affrontements n'ont fait aucune
victime au sein de la communauté
française
mais les femmes et des enfants français
se trouvant dans la ville ont été
évacués et depuis ce matin heureusement
violents opposent l'armée gabonaise et
des manifesto ces violents incidents
auraient fait un mort un soldat capturé
et battu à mort par les opposants il y
aurait aussi une quinzaine de blessés
une situation très inquiétante qui s'est
installé après l'annoncé de
l'arrestation de trois leaders de
l'opposition
en nous rejoignant tout de suite notre
envoyé spécial en direct à port gentil
pierre bade et quelle est la situation
sur place ce soir de la situation
le bilan est évidemment et
contradictoires mais êtes vous confiant
dans la reprise en un elle a déjà
commencé apprenti
je venais pas confirmée il s'agirait de
blessés parmi les parasites il se garde
qui lui réussit blessés parmi les
manifestants et 36 de ces manifestants
auraient cessé passé à tabac dans la
base navale c'est à dire à l'état major
des forces armées gabonaises
d'ailleurs le cas dans les sociétés
pétrolières pourraient repris leur
production de façon à pouvoir la
production normale de moeurs et 80 70
nous n'avons et pierre vous confirmer
que les fonctions guen est évacuée de la
de port gentil les regrouper en deux
fois l'hôtel le rac et quelques jours à
port gentil à l'étranger toujours
jérusalem secoué par de nouveaux
troubles cet après midi au lendemain de
l'attentât qui a fait un mort et une
dizaine de blessés légers israéliens ont
attaqué les voitures palestiniennes à
coups de pierres il n'y a pas eu de
victime
l'incident s'est produit malgré un
important dispositif policier d'ouvriers
sur ces images françois mitterrand lance
une mise en garde au patronat le chef de
l'état souhaite une revalorisation
rapide des bas et moyens salaires dans
un discours qualifié d' important par
l'elysée le président de la république a
mis l'accent à nouveau sur les
inégalités sociales trop criante à ses
yeux en france et s'est montré pour le
moins pressant reportages des terreaux
combattre l'exclusion les inégalités
partout où elles se trouvent
avec opiniâtreté c'est le message que
françois mitterrand a tenu à faire
passer ce matin à auxerre pour la ville
du ministre du travail et de l'emploi
jean pierre soisson
le président de la république en tant
que des mesures soient prises pour
limiter la spéculation
l'enrichissement sans cause mais surtout
il veut qu'un effort soit accomplie
maintenant pour augmenter les revenus
les plus bas
françois mitterrand a invité fermement
le patronat a négocié la revalorisation
des salaires avec les syndicats j'espère
qu'ils ont engagées pense par branches
des dialogues rapide et constructif il y
a urgence et il va de soi que si cette
voie contractuelle se révéler au bout du
compte impraticables ou trop décevante
enfin il faudrait procéder autrement et
cela ne se traduirait par une
intervention de l'état plus active
une mise en garde très claire à l'égard
du patronat qui sonne aussi comme une
recommandation au gouvernement
françois mitterrand l'a dit ce matin il
veut démontrer à l'occasion de son
deuxième septennat que la réussite
économique doit permettre d'accroître la
justice sociale le discours du chef de
l'état va relancer le débat feutré qui
se déroule en ce moment même au sein de
la majorité socialiste et qui porte sur
la politique économique et sociale de
michel rocard trop économique justement
aux yeux de certains socialistes et pas
assez social françois mitterrand s'est
bien gardée différents légion mais les
socialistes les plus critiques à l'égard
du gouvernement verront peut-être dans
les mots du chef de l'état comme un
encouragement
ont-ils raison pour autant pour le
savoir il faudra faire l'exégèse du
discours de françois mitterrand et là
mystère comme d'habitude
françois mitterrand souhaite que nos
gouvernements accélèrent la démarche
cela ressemble à une critique mais il
affirme dans le même temps agir en
relation étroite et en confiance avec le
gouvernement
cela annule la critique dans le même
temps à matignon s'ouvrait la seconde
table ronde sur l'immigration après une
valse hésitation qui a duré toute la
semaine les partis de l'opposition et
les centristes se sont finalement
décidés à participer à cette réunion
mais cette participation est plus
symbolique qu'autre chose il ne me
semble pas prêt en effet approuvé pour
autant la politique gouvernementale en
matière d'immigration
vous le voyez sur votre écran les
leaders de l'opposition sont arrivés à
17h45 sont ils toujours à l'intérieur de
matignon rappelle michel le merlan
direct et non poli sont en train de
sortir en ce moment même
depuis quelques instants les leaders
politiques se succèdent sur le perron
pour faire un certain nombre de
déclarations vous l'imaginez je vais
peut-être tout de suite vous faire
entendre celle d'alain juppé qui est le
premier à être sorti
c'est vraiment une page de cette gêne a
ensuite fait part de sa ferme intention
de ne pas toucher
au droit de la nationalité il nous en a
expliqué qu'il n'était pas question
d'abandonner
joxe pouvoir revenir à la noix fasse pas
dans ces conditions nous avons expliqué
que dp pas question de cautionner les
airs est repassé du bon air de mort les
gouvernements socialistes et son
inaction actuelle par conséquent cette
concertation
oui ici à madiba
c'est la base bien entendu nous autres
les autres déclarations dans nos
éditions de la soirée disons que
globalement aujourd'hui
cette journée a été ici un peu une
opération de clarification finalement
michel rocard à force de volonté
consensuelle avait donné parfois un peu
l'impression de flotter sur sa politique
d'immigration
de son côté l'opposition à coups de
volte/face permanence était un peu pris
les pieds dans le tapis de la table
ronde
finalement aujourd'hui chacun retrouver
ses positions et l'opposition a dit en
quelque sorte à michel rocard
aujourd'hui pour paraphraser lors
laurent fabius vous c'est vous et nous
c'est nous reprenez votre politique
faites vos textes ne sommes pas d'accord
avec eux l'essentiel de vos propositions
et puis nous prendrons notre décision le
moment venu
alain juppé s'est montré assez amer en
sortant de cette table ronde
donc oui alors consensus est désormais
exclue michel il y à un consensus sur un
certain nombre de mesures pratiques mais
y'a pas du tout en tout cas de consensus
de méthode
et cette méthode de la table ronde c'est
vraiment un point final elle n'aura plus
lieu hier oublions les divergences
politiques qui allons sur le terrain
c'est la vocation du 19 20
un exemple les aéroports et l'action des
fonctionnaires de la police de l'air et
des frontières pour eux les directives
gouvernementales sont claires parmi les
nombreuses missions
la chasse à l'immigré l'immigration
pardon clandestine ou irrégulière doit
être prioritaire à voici l'an passé 4200
personnes n'ont pas été admises à
rentrer sur le territoire français dans
ce cas ces personnes sont directement
refoulé est installée dans l'avion du
retour
reportage jean marc pitte et bernard
banques
on va voir sa copine
on va voir cinq officiers l'immigration
c'est à cet endroit que certains voyages
tourner court
le poste de contrôle de la police de
l'air et des frontières est pourtant
l'un des derniers obstacles
ces deux sénégalais ne le franchirons
pas ils ont accumulé trop de fautes
réservations d'hôtels bidon somme
d'argent insuffisante motif du
déplacement ambigu vérification et
interrogatoires s'impose le verdict est
ensuite de la responsabilité des
officiers c'est nous d'apprécier la
situation c'est-à-dire décide d'offrir
le maximum d'éléments pour bien voir
quelles sont leurs intentions
qu'est ce qui justifie effectivement
leur séjour sur le territoire national
le terme de cet examen de cas et bien
effectivement on décide le soir il
l'exemple et le cours suit comme
soi-même son ami noté nous sommes du
sénégal
moi mais la france et le sénégal sont
deux pays différents
non il n'a pas dû france c'est france
est quand même le sénégal mans mais
c'est fini maintenant la colonisation
s'est passé c'est pas fini
comment ce film l'ennemi ont le droit de
rester 24 heures en zone internationale
après quoi il leur faut regagner le pays
de départ
arrivé hier ces deux congolais ont passé
leurs délais de grâce dans un hôtel de
l'aéroport charles de gaulle
il était entré en france avec pour tout
moyen de subsistance un chèque de 6000
francs sur un compte clos depuis un an
ils repartent aujourd'hui pour
brazzaville
ces rapatriements se passe plus ou moins
bien
certains se débattent d'autres déchirent
leurs papiers dans l'avion par mesure de
précaution on confie leurs documents au
commandant de bord
ceux-ci n'oppose aucune résistance
à quoi bon car comme ils nous l'ont
confié ils reviendront
les policiers en tenue se sentirait tout
nu s'il était désarmé et ils l'ont fait
savoir d'une manière catégorique à
pierre joxe qui estimé hier qu'il y
avait trop de policiers armés en france
des fils me voient en france cent cinq
mille policiers sont armés ainsi que 80
mille gendarmes
la majorité d'entre eux souhaite le
rester en angleterre à londres sur vingt
mille policiers seuls 4000 bobbies ont
un certificat d'aptitude à porter une
arme et celle mille policiers sont
effectivement armés cette comparaison
entre ces deux polices faite par pierre
joxe vient renforcer son idée de
désarmer à terme une partie des
policiers français
une déclaration qui a provoqué de vives
réactions je ne suis pas du tout
convaincu que le miz intérieur pierre
joxe a bien l'intention de mettre en
application cette formule de désarmement
cas il aurait bien naturellement la
fédération dans sa globalité contre lui
tant qu'on a pas en france
la certitude que tous les truands soit
désarmé n'est pas question de parler
désarmement de la police
le ministère de l'intérieur n'a pas
dévoilé les statistiques sur
l'utilisation des armes dans la police
mais il est vrai que peu de policiers
sont amenés à se servir de leur revolver
au cours de leur carrière
environnement la polémique sur les
phosphates ne nagera plus en eaux
troubles
brice lalonde vient en effet de mettre
en place aujourd'hui une nouvelle
réglementation pas de décision coup de
poing juste un compromis qui va vers une
limitation progressive de l'utilisation
des phosphates
ils seront d'abord réduit de moitié
reportage pascal justice et flic dit les
phosphates ou pas phosphates les pubs de
lessive nous bassine
il ne s'agit plus désormais de lave et
blanc mais verts entendent et écologique
en vérité ce n'est pas la lessive qui
lave le linge mello le problème c'est
que la saleté une fois extraite du linge
coagule avec le calcaire de l'eau alors
c'est la rue des positions les
phosphates sont parfaits pour double
calcaire mais une fois répandue dans le
milieu aquatique il se comporte en
engrais résultat les algues se
multiplient créant un déséquilibre
écologique alors phosphate ou pas
phosphates
aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'environnement a tranché je considère
que dans un avenir que je souhaite le
plus proche possible les phosphates
devant être remplacé dès le 1er janvier
prochain elle est
meurant tripolyphosphate des nouveaux
produits de nouvelles formulations sont
à faire à 25% puis 20% au plus tard dans
un an chez rhône poulenc producteur de
phosphate
on craignait des mesures bien plus
sévère c'est une bonne décision
effectivement basée sur des éléments
scientifiques plus sérieux comme
référence le ministre a donc fait un
compromis il n'interdit pas les
phosphates comme en norvège ou en suisse
il en limite la quantité
comme plusieurs de nos voisins mais tant
qu'on n'aura pas trouvé un produit de
substitution ou un peu loin que les
phosphates
il nous faudra épuré nos eaux usées et
dans ce domaine on est en retard sur les
autres pays européens
drôles de touristes aujourd'hui à paris
des moutons sont entrés en nombre dans
la capitale par camions spéciaux les
éleveurs mécontents ont conduit leurs
compagnons de chant pour protester
contre la concurrence à leurs yeux
déloyale des moutons n'ait osé dans des
reportages de bernard sega rails de
dominique duchateau le mouton français
déprime depuis 1980 le cheptel ovin a
perdu plus d'un million de brebis soit
une baisse de 20% et d'ici la fin du
siècle
à ce rythme la france en perdra près de
40%
le véritable problème des éleveurs est
en fait le système européen trop
favorable selon eux à la grande bretagne
et aux pays du commonwealth
la nouvelle zélande et l'australie
notamment où la viande est un sous
produit de la laine mais aussi des pays
du sud où cette fois la viande est un
sous produit du lait bref bruxelles et
ses règlements inspire des sentiments
hostiles à nos éleveurs français tant
que la livre ne sera pas dans l'essai
mais il faut qu'il y ait un mécanisme
qui permette d'éviter qu'un pays puisse
bénéficier de la faiblesse de sa monnaie
pour pour exporter ce que nous réclamons
ce qu'un règlement équitable garanti
équitable mais chargé qui parle
la manifestation qui avait commencé dans
la bonne humeur s'est heurtée sur le
chemin du ministre d'agriculture aux
forces de police
quelques incidents ont eu lieu les
moutons de la colère portent bien leur
nom
à l'image de leur berger un télégramme à
l'instant deux employés de la préfecture
de police de paris et un médecin chef
ont été blessés en fin d'après midi à
l'intérieur des locaux de l'infirmerie
par un individu en état de démence
les trois personnes ont été poignardées
tout de suite les autres faits marquants
de l'actualité en france jean-françois
grégoire les trois skinheads inculpé
pour avoir profané 90 tombes d'un
cimetière à nantes ont été remises en
détention préventive après cinq jours de
prison il avait été remise en liberté
mercredi dernier mais le procureur de la
république est revenu sur l'avis du juge
en estimant que le maintien de l'ordre
public et la sécurité des accule p
justifie leur réincarcération
l'union de reims rhr paraîtra demain
depuis 11 jours les rémois étaient
privés de leur quotidien dans
l'imprimerie était fermée sur décision
de la direction
motif la parution sauvage d'une lettre
signée la cgt du livre
la direction a levé les sanctions et le
syndicat a fait savoir qu'il n'aurait
plus recours à ce genre de méthode mais
les discussions se poursuivent autour du
projet de modernisation du journal il
s'appelle gérard près de nazes il a 46
ans et est atteint d'une leucémie
après sept mois d'arrêt de travail il
est aujourd'hui licencié parce que son
médecin ne lui a pas prescrit d'arrêt
pour longue maladie
en prononçant ce licenciement le
directeur de la société n'a fait
qu'appliquer les textes de la convention
collective pour pouvoir conserver ce
poste devenu vacant dans sa société
un après midi de chien pour gérard
hurtaud pilote d'hélicoptère qui s'est
fait tirer dessus dimanche dernier à
bord de son appareil il survolait en
compagnie d'un photographe professionnel
une villa de ville sous dampjoux dans
l'isère lorsque son propriétaire lui a
envoyé une balle de calibre 12 en pleine
jambes
l'agriculteur aurait voulu protéger
l'intimité de son épouse et de ses deux
filles qui se baigner dans la piscine
placé en garde à vue il s'en explique
actuellement devant le juge de faux
évêque et deux faux prêtre aujourd'hui
devant le tribunal correctionnel d'agen
et il portait encore la sultane comme
pour mieux narguer ça qu'on leur
reproche une escroquerie ces religieux
entre guillemets faisait payer très cher
à des pèlerins un peu crédule une
apparition de la vierge le 14 de chaque
mois
l'argent disparaît dans death paraissait
en fait sur les comptes personnels de
ses pairs et ironie du sort c'est
monsieur seigneur un ancien de la
communauté du fréchou qui a porté
plainte contre eux claire sébastien
fréchou aux confins du lot-et-garonne et
du gers
c'est dans ce village que s'est
installée il ya 13 ans une communauté
religieuse traditionalistes discrète et
plutôt mystérieuses derrière ces murs
vivent une cinquantaine de religieux en
et femmes ainsi que deux prêtres et deux
évêques dont l'église ne reconnaît pas
les ordinations se sont fait tour donné
quatre froid prêtres et les deux
dernières fois prêtre évêque le même
jour dans des conditions parfaitement
aberrante tout à fait extraordinaire
communauté ou sectes la question est
posée mais difficile à trancher en 88
pourtant la faire basculer en justice
les aubes des fidèles eux disparaissent
sur les comptes personnels des
dirigeants
on parle alors de 3 millions de francs
de détournement mais aussi de pression
morale pour ces victimes un peu naïve
c'est une machine à broyer une machine à
broyer et ça ça fait peur qu'elle était
régenté par la communauté
je tirais même jusqu'au rapport sexuel
tout l'argent qui est rentré tous les
dons il rentrait dans la communauté
me serres fait que servir à nourrir et à
loger 50 religieux religieuses les faux
religieux se retrouvent pour deux jours
dans le box du tribunal correctionnel
d'agen le verdict est attendu avant la
fameuse apparition de la vie
h2 fréchou prévue le 14 de chaque mois
forget qualifié edberg becker éliminé
voilà les temps forts de la deuxième
journée des internationaux de france de
roland garros résumé de cette journée
par caroline since et jean-philippe rien
voici les futurs champions des années 90
goran ivanisevic 18 ans et demi
vainqueur de boris becker tête de série
numéro deux et demi finaliste l'an
dernier il va nicevic 43e mondial très
sûr de lui possède une extraordinaire
puissance de bras
il permet de résister à becker et même
de prendre le jeu à son compte dès
qu'elle remporte pourtant la première
manche 7 5
avant de lâcher les trois autres 6-4 7-5
6-2 les passings de fond de court du
gaucher yougoslave n'ont pas laissé au
numéro 3 mondial le temps de conquérir
le filet sur le central goran ivanisevic
était vraiment le plus fort
voici l'autre héros de roland garros
l'espagnol sergi bruguera 19 ans et
seulement 46e joueur mondial
il élimine stéphane adverse est de série
numéro 1 le finaliste de l'an dernier
les volets du suédois n'auront
fonctionner qu'en début du premier set
où il mène 4 2 francs après c'est la
dégringolade bruguera va aligner sept
jeux de suite
ed baird 2e joueur mondial est comme
paralysée trois sets 6 4 6 2 6 1 une
victoire surprenante et très facile pour
sergi bruguera qui rencontrera svensson
vainqueur de jérôme potier décidément
hedberg reste fâché avec la terre battue
cette saison
là
première apparition de la petite reine
jennifer capriati juste 14 ans la plus
jeune joueuse du circuit 6 1 6 1 pour
battre la pauvre lionel sandrine testud
entrée réussie pour jenny qui gagner le
tournoi juniors l'an dernier aura-t-elle
le même succès cette année
enfin si certains disent qu'un match et
parfois dans la poche pour forger c'est
la balle qui est dans le short et ça
porte bonheur
hélas trois à propos du tennis reste à
votre service si vous voulez tout savoir
à n'importe quel moment de la journée
n'hésitez pas à appeler le 36 65 21 2 x
36 65 21 deux fois il s'agit du
téléphone mais vous pouvez également
utiliser votre minitel 36 15 codes fr
trois concerts exceptionnels et uniques
de m'asseoir d'ella fitzgerald qui a
reçu les honneurs aujourd'hui avant le
succès demain après un demi-siècle de
gloire sur les scènes du monde entier la
ferrade a été décoré officiellement
aujourd'hui commandeur des arts et des
lettres par jack lang hommage d'un autre
fan de toujours jacques dernier 55 ans
de carrière et se sentir toujours aussi
timide telle une communiante aussi
moqueuse comme une harpe est grave comme
un fondé de pouvoir est là
la première dame du jazz ne changera
jamais les honneurs tombe elle en sourit
et la médaille qu'elle a reçu
aujourd'hui sera en bonne place rassurez
vous dans sa résidence de beverly hills
parmi des centaines d'autres cousteau le
français le plus populaire aux states et
des nappes est elle a été ravie la même
génération de coeur toujours aussi jeune
aussi
et là appartient à l'histoire
demain soir paris lui fera fait elle
aime tellement chanté et qui pourrait
l'en empêcher
venir
je vous rappelle les trois informations
du jour plutôt de la soirée en tennis
qualification de forget après noah et
leconte c'est une bonne nouvelle en
revanche des fêtes de becker edberg du
numéro trois du numéro 2 mondiaux en
politique mise en garde de françois
mitterrand aujourd'hui au patronat il
souhaite une revalorisation quasi
immédiate des bas salaires et des moyens
salaires en politique également pas
d'accord entre l'opposition et michel
rocard entre l'opposition et la majorité
sur l'immigration les chefs de
l'opposition se sont bien rendus
aujourd'hui à 17h45 à l'hôtel matignon
mais ils sont ressortis apparemment déçu
tout le monde les il n'y a pas de
consensus sur la politique de
l'immigration en france on y reviendra
bien sûr dans le journal de marque
hautement ce soir à 22h15 les programmes
sur l'a3 ce soir à 20h35 la marche du
siècle présentée par jean marie cavada
avec un dossier spécial sur la chine un
an plus tard et un document exceptionnel
du cinéma à 22h45 avec un western inédit
ronson luxe
un film américain de frank perry tout de
suite la météo complète de florence que
la fin de ce 19 20 bonsoir à demain 19h
bonsoir
nous